the stakes are the stakes of human
freedom which depends upon a view of
human nature
and the government that's appropriate to
that
[Music]
the greatest political science started
with the classics when they begin to
study the regimes and the worst of all
the kinds of regimes is tyranny
the rule is in the interest of the ruler
and that means that the others are held
by force
they're in greater or lesser states of
rebellion all the time
in the 20th century a new word was
invented for tyranny they called it
totalitarianism
in the soviet union what what happens
right your kids
have to go to school if they don't
you're arrested but then what are they
taught in school
they're taught to inform on you
people live in terror of their own
children
because the children are young right and
they can't and so they go to school and
they hear
you know authoritative things and
you'd be afraid to tell the children not
to believe what's in school
because how can you trust a 10 year old
not to repeat what you said and to the
extent that you can teach them things
like that
you are depriving them of their
childhood
that's totalitarianism i don't myself
think
that it's really different in principle
than ancient tyranny which is also at
war with human nature
the classic books raised the question
how can a tyrant perpetuate himself
because they don't last very long these
tyrannies people don't like them
and a famous story repeated by aristotle
that they do it by lopping off
everything tall everything excellent
everything's superior uh a tyrant stands
in a field of grain and lops off all the
top
higher heads of grain and that point you
can't have friendship you can't have
philosophy you can't have faith
because those are all things that look
both
closer inside the human being not just
to the tyrant
and look above the tyrant too and
hitler and stalin just like
you know the great greek tyrants and the
roman ones
they suppress everything
private and everything high
except now what changes is the scale is
so much
bigger and it becomes plausible that you
could actually remake the world
and then the use of technology makes it
ever more potentially intense
about 60 million people were killed in
the war
about half of them soldiers sailors and
airmen
and about half of them civilians
that's that's you know three times as
much as the first world war
[Music]
the body count is just massive there are
big reasons why the war
is so severe for civilians just all
because
technology and accumulated wealth
make it possible to wage a more
total kind of war even than was waged in
the first world war which was
incredibly terrible and unprecedented
and then the second thing is there was a
mass-produced
organized effort to murder
people whole categories of people whole
races of people
whole professions of people nobody had
ever seen
anything like that before there's an
organized attempt
at mass slaughter that's totalitarianism
one of the most articulate into my mind
finest human beings who ever lived was
winston churchill
who was a friend of freedom
parliamentary democracy
freedom under a constitution freedom
with restraint
every person he loved to quote can live
by no man's leave beneath the law
however humble that person is born
the government is to be accountable to
the people churchill said that there's
always two options are the people going
to belong to the government
or is the government going to belong to
the people he just
repeated that all his life and he
thought that these great totalitarian
tyrannies
which he thought that the extremist
movements in his
own country including the socialist
party that he opposed all his life and
was
beaten by in 1945 echoed in a milder
form
the same thing as these tyrannies
because they too
had this sort of notion that we can
perfect the society if we just assemble
more power
in the people who lead it so
it is a great contest and it's confused
by between these two ways of looking at
the world
right and they really do amount to
whether you have a picture of the human
soul that it's free
and therefore entitled to govern itself
which means
never to be governed except with its
consent
different than from horses and dogs and
all the things that we use for pets
or this view that no in the end we're
collective beings shaped by history
and now we're going to appoint some of
us to get control of the effort to shape
history
and and so the stakes
are the stakes of human freedom
which depends upon a view of human
nature
and the government that's appropriate to
that
and that battle still goes on
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and invite
you to explore our complete course
on the second world wars all of
hillsdale college's online courses are
free
and for everyone who loves to learn